بيقعدوا الرئيس الامريكي السابق والمرشح
للرئاسه دونالد ترامب ليتصدر الاخبار في
القضيه الجنائيه التي يواجهها بتهمه تزوير
سجلات تجاريه مقابل دفع اموال لشراء صمت
الممثله الاباحيه
2016 الجديد هو اصدار القاضي اخوان مرشن
في الوصول الى الادله التي تم تسليمها الى
فريقه ومن نوعه من نسخ او نشر او كشف اي
ادله في القضيه على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي من دون الحصول على موافقه من
المحكمه ولا يمكن للترامب ان يطلع على اي
معلومات حساسه بخصوص هذه القضيه من دون
حضور محاميه ولا يسمح له كذلك بحيازه اي
دليل بصوره مستقله وطلب مكتب المدعي العام
في منهات امر الحمايه هذا بسبب مخاوف من
ان ترامب قد يستخدم تلك الادله بشكل غير
لائق او ينشر المعلومات على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي او في مكان اخر خاصه
وان ترامب يجد في منصاته تشوز سوشل ملاذا
يشارك من خلالها كل ما يدور في راسه وما
يواجهه مع الملايين من متابعيهم
طبعا عرض محاموه ترامب هذا الامر كون لان
الوثائق والمراسلات وغيرها تعتبر من
العناصر المتبادله بين الاطراف المتنازعه
في قضيه قانونيه قبل المحاكمه وانتهاك لحق
ترامب مشاهدينا لتذكير ترامب كان قد مثل
امام المحكمه الشهر الماضي للتحقيق معه في
اربع وثلاثين تهمه جنائيه وذلك بخصوص
شرائه الصمت
مقابل
130 الف دولار قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه في
2016 المبلغ كان قد دفعه محامي ترامب
السابق مايكل كوهن والذي اعترف بالامر لكن
ترامب كان قد اكد ان الاموال كانت مقابل
نفقات قانونيه للعمل وكان قد نفى كل هذه
التهم الموجهه ضده هذا تطور يجعلنا تساءل
ان كانت قضيه الاحتيال المحاسبيه
والضريبيه هذه وغيرها من القضايا المتهم
فيها ترامب والتي كان اخرها اتهامه من قبل
الكاتبه الامريكيه اي جين كارول وتشويه
سمعتها ستعرقل نجاح ترامب في الانتخابات
ام انها لن تؤثر عليه وانما بالعكس ربما
تثبت براءته قبل الانتخابات وتزيد من
شعبيته اذا الاسئله كثيره تدور حول مصير
الرئيس الاكثر جدليه في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده على كل هذه الاسئله كلها للاجابه
عليها ينضم الينا من جده الدكتور بندر
الدوشي الباحث الشان الامريكي دكتور اهلا
بك معنا في تفاعلكم وفي العربيه
يتخذ من منصته
ليشارك ملايين من متابعي على هذه المنصه
كل ما يدور في راسه اولا هذا القرار
بتقييد وصوله الى الادله الجنائيه الى هو
مبرر
نعم حياكم الله اولا يجب
غير المسبوق بشخصيه سياسيه متنافسه او
تنافس
خصم سياسي ينافس الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
وبالتالي ما يحدث هو اصلا ما يحدث هو نوع
من الاضطهاد السياسي ثم بعد ذلك كان
متوقعا ايضا تقييد الرئيس الامريكي السابق
من الحديث حول هذه القضيه
ومنع النشر في هذا المجال واعتقد ان هناك
عده جوانب في هذا
هناك نوع من الطوار
الديمقراطي لماذا هذه النتيجه هناك موصف
فان النتيجه نوع من التعذيب للديمقراطيين
وان هناك يجب ان تبحث الحزب الديمقراطي ما
نبحث عن استراتيجيه او النظر وراع الاسباب
التي دفعت بالمستقلين والمعتدلين
المعتدلين الحزب الجمهوري الالتصاق
بالترام ودعمه في امام
هذا هذا بالنسبه لساحه المعترك السياسي
على ساحه مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ترامب
يملك 146 مليون متابع على مواقع التواصل
بينها خمس ملايين متابع على منصه التي
ينشط فيها اليوم الى اي مدى مواقع التواصل
اليوم قد تكون محفز للترامب وقد تكون
خادمه للترامب بهدف الوصول لرئاسه في 2012
[موسيقى]
الاجتماعيه ترامب شخصيه وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تبحث عن عوده الترامب واين
تويتر كيف اعادت رمل وكيف ان ايلون ماسك
كان ينحني الى ترامب للرغبه في عادته
لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي للرغبه في البدء
بالتغريد مجددا فيسبوك اعاده رمل يوتيوب
اعاده رمل هو وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
غير مجدي او غير متفاعله ترامب هو من يحيي
تويتر وهو من يبحث عنه ماسك الان ترامب في
منصه
فعال في عرض قضيته في عرض مضرونيه في
مهاجمه دي سانتوس في مهاجمه الديمقراطيه
في مهاجمه اليسار وبالتالي القضيه الاكبر
التي بوينت التي ستقوم مؤثره
القويه او في جانب ترامب هو متى يبدا
بالتغريد العوده الى التغريد في حساب
تويتر نعرف ان حسابه في تويتر مليون يعني
ملايين المتابعين من حول العالم يتابعون
الرئيس الامريكي وبالتالي تاثيره هاي على
تويتر واعتقد انه
سيكون من
واذا ارادت رمى العوده الى الرياسه عام
2024 عليه ان يضبط صلوحه وعليه ضبط خطابي
المتهور ضد الخصوم عليه
نفسه من التحدث في قضايا ليس له علاقه
بالحديث بها وبالتالي اعتقد ان الجمهوريون
هناك من الاستراتيجية يعتبرون ان التعرم
على تويتر هذه الايام ونعم هم لا يريدون
ترامب العوده الى تويتر واثاره القضايا
الجذريه مجددا هو الان يتقدم في استطلاعات
الراي مرتاح لهذا بهذا المسلك لكن
الديمقراطيين في اعتقادي
يحاولون بثارتهم مجددا بالكثير من القضايا
الكثير من الاتهامات حتى يجبرونه عوده الى
تويتر والتدخل في قضايا كبيره او تثير او
الانقسام في داخل الامريكي واعتقد ان هذا
الناس سيحصل عليه في الانتخابات عام 2004
من جده حدثنا دكتور بندر الدوش الباحث في
الشان الامريكي شكرا جزيلا لك على تواجدك
معنا دكتور
[موسيقى]